hey guys I'm Ryan right hello there I'm
Veronica so we're gonna check out a
video from the brown nerd Siri comment
trolling iv4 hmm alright here we go
strong language you message from Dave
okay I'm coming library ever sausage
from date okay I am coming over to the
library to have sex with you there we
are going to have to be very quiet
because I don't want to be spotted wine
coming in your mouth
last night when me and my sister were
going up cause I ate no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] game attention everyone we
will be closing the library in 10
minutes because someone is having gay
sex in the bathroom we apologize for the
inconvenience
this is a funny [ __ ] this is your
emergency broadcast system announcing
the commencement of the for your
participation
what are you sentences
you think it [ __ ] why are you doing
that yet you the girl with the
headphones on stop staring at me how do
you think do that any of you [ __ ]
wanna go to my 46th birthday party there
will be cocaine morning - for marijuana
tonight I want guys like you attention
psycho attention [ __ ] this [ __ ] is open
for the price of only four dollars every
half hour come on down and get the robot
cop attention everyone
I need Compton bias immediately I am
taking applications at the front desk
right now first come first serve hum
clever great trolling oh excuse me why
is it so quiet in this library does
anyone want to have sex on the table and
maybe get an orgy yeah that's what I
would have real
yo what's up guys thanks for watching
it's been a while since I've made one of
these
anyways follow me on the insta cracks
the waters and the book of the face
let's try to get this to 10 million
likes and don't forget to share this
with your mom
and guess what Papa Papa please click to
score some [ __ ] like his annotations
and tags it's kind of inspiring ok do
brown nerd you've earned my subscription
my friend Wow only has a hundred
seventy-two thousand subs this guy
deserves more subs that was [ __ ]
hilarious some of those sentences just
were so [ __ ] yeah it was really fun
hey I can't imagine what it would be
like I think I would laugh man I would
crack up I heard that in a library
I'd probably stand up and say okay who
did it Deborah who did it everyone had
the same response of like huh and it's
I'm just giggle woman but I would have
been dying of laughter if I heard that
in the library I probably would just be
like in shock I would probably react the
same way I reacted when I watched so
when I did my reaction you know he's got
that I would have done it even darker
you know I would have been like I have
your baby I'm stabbing it in the eye
right now the heading it and then
putting its head on a stick that would
have been funny that would have been
funny or I'm going to murder those
people outside with the loud music I'm
gonna take their children kill them in
front of them and then I'm going to [ __ ]
on the parents bodies the [ __ ] I come up
with this is so [ __ ] witty and funny
oh god this is why I pray at night hey
these are just jokes baby I mean I hate
that music tit well that's not really
recent well I said some racist
it's always [ __ ] in like you can say
you're half Mexican
I am half Mexican but they're always
playing Spanish music and it's usually
Mexican traditional they blast it it's
just oh okay but I don't want to kill
the kids so oh well killing kids is for
the fun okay never mind
that's me it needs to stop okay just
reading these descriptions sounds so
funny of his videos McDonald's double
cheeseburger Oh nobody you eat a sir but
blind man drops marijuana experiment do
do is this guy haven't never seen a ship
before there's some funny-ass stuff
anyway dude yeah if you're in LA we got
a collab in some way I got to get
involved in your projects where you at
where you at man around man I got to
start working with you
sounds like you and I have a very
similar sense of humor oh no you know
well imagine turn down juries though
imagine two of us both of us huh
I wonder if he has a girlfriend come on
guy like that nah yeah I think he has a
girlfriend if it's another guy like me
same sense of humor both of us in the
bedroom with you I'm not gonna comment
he's called that brown nerd so you know
what hole he be getting
what is wrong with you no makeup sex no
no man no sex you've been so obnoxious
lately I know not even just a home
camera off camera on camera whoa if
there's more than just us in the room
it's gonna generate a reaction out of
you
hence the funny I'm so glad that they're
getting a kick out of this you guys
getting a kick out of this cuz if you
are you're a [ __ ] fool now there's
gonna be a lot of comments saying well I
guess I'm a [ __ ] ass anyway guys
thanks for tuning into the Chanel if
you're new today subscribe by clicking
this button become a reject today I
guess we have a name for this channel
such a youtuber thing to do
I don't know against it music is so loud
why is that so loud is like was like no
respect for the neighborhood no respect
dude they blast it like they're having a
freakin party every day for hours and
hours and hours we should go tell them
something come on you know I'm not good
with confrontation you're scared of them
weren't you of course I'm scared of them
they're half you I think it's the ones
where you you remember you threw up on
that that car it's not them but if
that's them throw up on their car again
that's for damn sure
you can check out Veronica's Channel
acoustic covers what that means is she
takes a song it takes her acoustic
guitar and does a cover this song it's
pretty good stuff and there's vlogs on
there too video blogs okay there you go
happy okay you know what we have you
something about this now I'm gonna call
the manager what I'm titling this the
white man's way can you tell them some
huh I let my girlfriend handle our tough
business
I wasn't able to see the workers with
the people working next to us are
blasting her music like incredibly loud
is there a way where I might be able to
ask him just to turn it down a little
bit
thank you
i no white man way Mexican way you step
in be tough
white man scared calls authority tries
not to let them know that it was me the
American I'm just solving the problem
right here the American Way
you know the manager probably wouldn't
even do anything about it that's my
point
and I still relied on her